D
REON AND SENCE GAT T
SEYOU NIT.
THANK U SOUCHTH LIEABOU TANDEMIC
D NOW ITEEMSHEY E
ING  UTO TE U TO WAR
SHOUAVEEEN FED HIS
SGRA OR AHANIAN
PINGP RUSSIA MILARY
THRE TO E RAIN AND
FOREN-POLICY MAKIN A FL
HIMLF IN AMECA SLY
UKRAE TD H OVER T TOP
ANNONCE WITHHE BENLS
MINIRATION LA THPEOP
HEAIDEOULDELPO
RUSSNS TRY T MEROGRESS
PLOMICALLY BMEETG WI
THFRENCH A THEERMA
RUSSIA TINVA ANOER
REVOTION.CRU OUR
ANTHENO FFERNDER
COMMISM.
AMERICA. CNTRY NOW
AT WANTO KW IS WH OUR
LEERSREN THE THATS OUCOUNY ANHIE
ENER ANDASSION TY HAV.
E TABLHMENSEEMS OF
ALL OVER AIN.NG RUSSI
STISTEAGAITO THE
POOUS GRANDSTDING FROBO PARES OY
OWS LKINGBO A BL
EY WT TO PAS THI CING
WE.
>> IANT NCTIS ON PIN'S
HAOR>>ANCTNS.
>> SCTIO.
SANCTIO.
>>ANCTNS.>>ANCTNS.
>> TSERE SCTIO BEYOND
Y WE HAVEVEREVERE
>> TY E CRPLIN TO THE
ONOMY.
.
EVE: THEWANTHE MHEOF
GREASATIONRIGHNOW.
CHINA?ERARE EY AIN
TACKING R COTRY R
ARS.
E KINDS HIS THA IS
SANCTIONWHERTHEUSA
CYBERAACKSN UKINE TO
DEABIZINTHE ONOMY.
TH SURE SODS FILIAND
HAS BE LAUHING
CYBETTAC F YRS.
FEDERAL VERNNT'S OFFES?
THEYTOLEHENFORMATIOR
ERYBY THEY HE WOED F
UNITED STESOVERENT.CHA HABEENESG
R ECOMYOR DECES TODEROY L WOINGD
STEANG O INTELLEUAL
PROPTY.
FORCG U COMPAES LE
SNEY TO VE CMUNI PARTY
CELL
EY S WNEEDRGEN
SATIONON RUSSIBECAE O
WHERE ARTHE GENTANCTIONS
SP CHA'S LITARY
MAUVERS TH AREOSTI?
YING TO VADEAIWAOR
NTROTHSOUT CHI SEA?
LEERSHIPS D MSILES.
HOW ULD  FEEL IFUR
EMIE WER IN OURWN
CKRD?WH WILTHISSTLISHNT
BACKYARD AGGSSIVYOUR
PANDG ITS INUENCIN TCABBEABUILNN
JAIC ANDOMPUTERSO
HOOLDS ITHE DOMICAN
REPUIC A INFSTCTURAN VENUELA ANE
LISTING ATNN
GENTA.WI CHI REAY HELP TSE
UNT?
AGNST ERICAND THENHAT
ABOUALL  THEMECANS THE
INEEGIME H KILD
ROUGTHE PDEMI?
EY POUR UGS TO T
LAST YR MOLY D TOEOSES
NTAN WHICH CNA I T
IMAR SRCE.
ESENT  IS BRAL
STOP ALLHIS T HEHOOSES
US. BECSE HIS ATTACNG
ESTAISHMENT  INHE
INA,OME  THEM
TERAY.
FAMILY WHOROHT LRATI
DES INORCED BINES TS
TH SATOREINSTEINAS
CHINESEOMMUST PAR IMA
ANN
MCCOL WAS CUSEOFH
USINHER FI TO LP H
DEAL CPANY WITTHE INA
TH WOROUR SYST CNESE
TO SPE TIR IEREST A
INFIRATO UNIRSITS IN
INLLTUALROPEY AND BY
POWER OV FD SPLY.AI
EN WL WEE SERIOU ABOCHA?
EN?
OUESTAISHMENT  A
OW-MION TIONAL SCIDE
TO G ALLXCIT AUT
SENDINTROO TOASTERN
EURO WHIINA NEAND
DO THE HARD WK TO UNREL
D RER THE DEA